let's return our attention to the
ongoing conflict in Sudan now and the
head of the Sudanese Army has said that
the UK the U.S France and China are
pulling people out that does is the
fighting their intensifies for
humanitarian workers of course living in
the country's capital the situation has
become increasingly dangerous well
joining me now is Thomas akidi he's a
humanitarian worker for the Norwegian
Refugee Council based in Sudan uh Thomas
good of you to take the time to talk to
us um what is happening in cartoon as we
speak
very much I am not best in cartoon
however I am best in El fascia which is
a city in Northern Sudan so I can
authoritatively talk about El fascia but
not necessarily about cartoon because
I'm not best there
no fair enough so what is happening
Where You Are
so El fascia this is day number eight of
the conflict
the world knows that the conflict in
Sudan started on Saturday last week
and for El fascia the first five days of
the conflict were intense
meaning there was a lot of gunfire there
was Heavy Artillery neighborhoods and uh
some people were injured and they also
reported mothers and killings of people
so the first five days of the conflict
were extremely extremely intense the
last 24 to 48 hours have been relatively
calm as people celebrate uh the end of
the holy month of Ramadan however the
challenge in El fashion now is that
people are lacking basic Services there
is no electricity in the city and right
now it is 41 degrees centigrade in this
summer there is no water in households
food is fast running out in the city
because all the supply lines for the
food which are basically districts or
localities outside of the city
every other supplier is scared of trying
to come into the City and make the
dangerous journey into the city to
supply food
we had one of our markets here called
Abu shock Market uh Catch Fire during
the week and reports indicate that some
hoodlums who want to take advantage of
what was happening in terms of the
conflict basically set the fire on the
market so that they could be able to
loot but those are all uncom unconfirmed
accounts of the cause of the fire the
prices of basic Commodities have more
than tripled and yet there is a lot of
scarcity for these very basic
commodities and as a humanitarian worker
what efforts are being made to get some
of those basic supplies in
the challenge is that humanitarian
workers do not have any guarantee of
safety to access populations in need
both in the city but also in the IDP
comes out of the city
so for humanitarian workers for the last
one week it's also been about safety and
survival most of us are hibernating in
our homes I manage a team of 55 staff
many of which have not been able to even
move out of their own house because of
fear of you know being caught up in
crossfire or fear of looting or boundary
boundary that's currently becoming very
common so humanitarians have no access
and the safety of humanitarians is
currently not guaranteed within the
context where we're working so nothing
is happening in terms of humanitarian
work
and of course it's Eid isn't it it's a
time that would normally be one of joy
and celebration
it must seem very incongruous
it's a very sombre mood I must say
because yesterday I sent out a message
to my staff and told them please enjoy
the Eid holiday but I also knew it was
going to be a very challenging holiday
for them because instead of being one of
Tears instead of being one of Joy it was
a holiday to you know try to keep safe
they hold the biscal to try to survive
so
and it's even worse for the internally
displaced persons of North dafu before
the conflict there were already 871
000 people who were internally displaced
we don't know how many more people have
been internally displaced because of
this conflict and because no
humanitarian organizations delivering
services in terms of water in terms of
food assistance in terms of medical care
internally displaced persons in North
dafu are extremely suffering and it is
time for the world to act so that we can
be able to access these suffering
populations in their physics in the idea
Becomes of Northstar
all right uh Thomas good to talk to you
thank you for taking the time to speak
to us and uh good luck getting some of
those Provisions to the people who need
it
thank you very much and thank you for
the opportunity to amplify the voice of
the internet displaced persons in North
dafu
thank you